what's happening with you my friend yeah
um i've got two leads in actual fact
um i just wanted to before i proceeded i
wanted to ask your advice this evening
if that's all right
of course um i had a house going through
before corvid
i was buying um and i pulled out
it went right to sign and i pulled out
just um
just before everything happened um until
you know so with carving
and i know the ladies in negative equity
um i know that how she's mortgaged up to
the hilt with it
i know she wants to move to rent yeah
wants to be nearer to a kid's school
um i know a name i've got contact with
her
and i just wondered what which would be
the way would you send a letter or would
you
go and knock on the door or especially
in this current situation with corvid
how would you i do both i do both
knocking on someone's door is is
is not that bad right now i don't think
we've covered as long as you just keep
right back
you're not like hi um as long as you
keep right back
and keep your distance i feel like
people now are much
um a much more relaxed and and people
got mixed opinions on that and
i don't have an opinion on that i don't
know what i think of that
um i would do both a little tip as well
as is
when you do both it's actually a good
excuse knocking the door is a good
excuse if you send a letter first
because you can send a letter
and then a week later you can knock the
door you can say hi my name's chris
i sent you a letter last week i'm just
checking you got it yeah
like it's like making a phone call to
someone after sending a text
you know you send it you see
from spare room and say hey my name's
chris i'm i'm look i'd love to give you
a guaranteed rent offer or potentially
buy your hmo
text me back if you're interested call a
week later hey it's chris did you get my
text last week i bet you hmo you know
it's like a follow-up so i'm always into
i'm always a both man rather than
which which which point of contact
should i do i'm like
both right yeah because it's one of
those it's a good lead that you didn't
want to ruin it it sounds
daft isn't it really and it's those
types of leads
you don't want to be emotionally
attached but you take those types of
leads down
and that's the power of follow-up if
you've got a good opportunity
you know the situation it's like i'm not
leaving that alone
no i'm not going to put all my eggs in
that basket i'm going to have other
stuff going on
but that is not going to slip i'm going
to keep following up until that lady
says absolutely no or okay let's do this
right yep another thing as well on this
call
is because i know that people are
getting close to completions and there's
and there's people that have got
you know people conversations going on
i'm very happy to answer any
legal questions or or xyz
questions about legal stuff if people
have got those because at this point
when you start putting forward offers
and stuff
it can get a bit scary and you can get
sellers saying stuff like but what about
if you die and all this sort of stuff
well chris
that's amazing and i'm excited to see
what happens brilliant yeah i've
actually got a second one that
um i actually offered in illinois um
yes when i didn't really know what i was
doing okay
so it's a house that um is
actually he's a manager of an estate
um oh so he's he's had i mean he's took
it off the market
in november to refurb it put it back on
in january
fully reefer 15 grand more expensive
and they still couldn't sell it's just
been dropping again
he's taking it off the market again now
but i've got his contacts i've already
spoken to him
really yeah again what would you say to
him i would say to him
hey i'm really i'm interested in your
property i know she took it off the
market
are you still open for business yeah
what happened with it because i'm an
investor
um what you know what's the story oh you
know couldn't sell it decided
to just keep it and rent it out cool
have you got a tenant yet yeah i have no
i haven't
okay cool listen um i know it's on for
150 or whatever it's on for
um i'm an investor you know i'd probably
only likely be able to
offer about 120 but as i know you've had
a bit of trouble selling it i don't know
what are your thoughts on that
no no i couldn't go that low that's why
i've taken it off the market because i
keep getting stupid offers like that
okay
well i may be able to do something like
this i can give you 150 which is what
you want
but not for six years because i want to
give the market chance to recover
however in the meantime i'll be able to
take on any mortgage payments or costs
associated
that you've got with the property on a
monthly basis how does something like
that sound
i'll pass them on to you
or watch the recording of this and just
memorize
the language but you'll just get better
it's like if if
if i don't know what what you guys do
for for a day job but if your day job is
you are
you know a librarian and when people
come in you say you know how can i help
what can i
you just you just do it automatically or
if you drive
you know if you guys i'm sure mostly
drive if you drive you just the first
time you started driving a car
you were stalling and you were like was
such a big
deal and then now you just jump in a car
and you just
get where you want to go without
thinking and it's the exact same with
securing deals you know and that's why
when you get good at this you can
your first deal is always your hardest
then your second deal is always the
second hardest
and by the time you've done your 100th
deal and bear in mind i've done over 300
property deals
so for me it's just absolute second
nature
and and it will become that and everyone
that's on the call is a competent person
an intelligent person
a driven person the fact that you're on
the call the fact that you're still here
after after three four weeks
you know it's gonna happen it's just a
matter of it's just a matter of
when it happens but and and and
potentially even on a bigger scale than
i thought
some of the deals that you guys have got
in the bag are really big deals
the deal that rhett's got the deal that
rafael's got the deal that
um what's his name um a couple of guys
speaking to
a few members ago but but some of them
are quite big deals where you could
potentially
be financially free from one or two of
those types so
chris excited for you good to see you on
the deal selling masterclass as well
yeah really enjoying it yeah right
as well what's that sorry second
everything what everybody else has said
about
it as well the amount you give back is
is is um
you know the integrity you've used and
everything is uh is exceptional
thank you chris that's that really does
mean a lot thank you so much
thanks for saying